for the ninth weekend in a row Israelis
have taken to the streets in all major
cities to protest against the Netanyahu
government this was outside the
president's house in Jerusalem they're
trying to prevent radical judicial
reforms which would allow the parliament
to overrule the Supreme Court with a
simple majority of one I want a free
speech I own a free country I want the
same right for every person of every
religion of every nationality like you
have it in a democracy we can't stay
home we have to go and fight because we
were in the last 12 minutes
the protests have been growing every
week and becoming more frequent in Tel
Aviv more than a hundred and sixty
thousand took to the streets
what is very
illustrations
[Music]
of Israeli Society religious secular
private sector public sector young old
even Israeli military reservists have
been demonstrating because the ANSI
government feeling now is very white
the weekly demonstrations have been
largely peaceful but some recent
violence has led senior opposition
ministers to warn that Israel could be
heading towards a civil war
it is a dramatic political sound bite
that gets the headlines but Israeli
Society is for sure divided well we came
because we are afraid about the future
of our kids
afraid that we will become a
dictatorship instead of the Democracy
that we have right now
do you believe National
government dictator absolutely
the Israeli president has called for
both sides to negotiate and compromise
but the Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu has so far shown no
willingness to do that
the far right have wanted these reforms
for years now that they're finally part
of the government they're not going to
back down whatever the consequences
Aleister bunker Sky News in Jerusalem